nemesis much better than the Star Trek
movie I never said there isn't too much
um alright so this is an episode where
Oh what's the characters they're just
welcome Momo by now is that were these
calls piece master B's master yes get
recalled the piece master beast or piece
east master oh those Peas no Beast
Master because you can like Kodo and
podo and I think I see you through a
panther I think it's a piece okay III
get what you're talking about though
it's very clear you know that's not
really about so here's a character who
is against Princess Bubblegum and all
her cameras being everywhere and says he
will take her down but he is also a
single father the minivan with three
kids tries to look after you know all
their puking and stuff and he blames
that you know again bubblegum for the
fact that he can't keep things to
balance that could be these trying to be
like a vigilante superhero and raise a
family
so so peppermint Butler goes and uses
his Dark Arts through the 80s music
video sorry sir it's uh sounds like the
Friz ain't gay my head Terry but you
said the lyrics really very nicely done
though yeah don't know what it was but
again yeah I like those little touches
when they do something just a little
different so they decide to have this
great big battle and Butler pretty much
very evil eaters his kids into monsters
unless he gives up all his little
trinkets and magical elements and he
does so he has two little monsters and
one normal kid as normal as a you know
block guy kid whatever can be and yeah
Butler goes back and gets bubblegum her
tea and try it off in his minivan
and he makes a meet dirt that was too
far let's show your underwear looking
like a chicken now eat some dirt me stop
stop I took that too far and yeah that's
essentially the episode well we'll say
the first thing that we are all shouting
when that moment happened where the hell
is that my last episode yeah yeah I took
this too far it's like there's that's a
perfect example of like going really
mean but like you know balancing and
obviously oh well I just know you know
and it's great sing and do that why is
it someone who partakes in the Black
Arts that that gets cinnamon bun
possessed and all of that stuff it's the
one that goes eating dirt I've gone a
bit too far on this yeah it's a great
job it's a really funny joke
um the I can't tell this is setting up
something or it's if it's just an
entirely pointless episode whoa but
either way I had a good laugh I like
this character this is this piece master
guy um I really love that he has a
family and they it's a single father and
everything that jet and the minivan has
family really cracked me up uh I like
little touches like that it I like when
they bring in the family dynamic into
something where you don't normally see
it and like that's the one thing I like
the district 9 I love how that you know
he was a single father like I've never
seen an alien single father okay you
know like I'll give it that
uh as the same thing here with the
mini-myth enemy mine kind of that's a
stretch so that's why I've never saw
aliens and your father obviously uh but
yeah but but I like that element here
it's it's a great contrast it's funny
but also kind of shows this is one for
his kids you know like that's kind of
cool I love how the kids like be
monsters although the girl got off
pretty nice this is like she's got these
cute little wings and like a little
crabs like wow you got like a tail like
we're the boys like a friggin drag him
that like doesn't have fingers anymore
girl but they go to the parking flies
yeah
yeah and there are two kind of happy to
be monster however they want to do want
to go look at dark art she's like no
dark arts is bad for you yeah so it's
it's so it's funny and so it's a funny
dynamic um so yeah and again very little
Finn and Jake which is again better than
the last one where we get no Finn and
Jake yeah um that is the I don't know
two in a row without them though it does
no I got it was a three in a row I think
like to know cuz remember the the wizard
won all that you're right yeah yeah
three in a row where they're not the
main focus that's a little weird you
know what though but the wizard one was
a great episode and this I think I
thought this was a great episode I had a
lot of fun with this one and the only
one in it like was the LSP one it is a
little weird seeing I'm like in a row
without Finn and Jake I mean I do
realize this I really do I mean I never
dislike them but I am like yeah I do
miss them after a while no not seeing
him a couple times
um next one I don't think we've seen
much of them either yeah
wait you haven't seen it I know but the
title you'll see okay um so yeah no I I
thought was fun to get had a lot of old
cameos back in and then the point you
brought up that I thought too is piece
master related to what's any of that
wizard run James yeah Ron James yeah way
to ride Jake's it looks a lot like oh
yeah that's what what do you think this
is that way that's what I thought like
it's that yeah James in disguise
that's what I thought too so maybe it's
like a relative or something I'm really
curious
all of them squares look alike oh-ho
yeah I went there
I'm oh and technically it's a wreck
right hang on
I'm at that sounded really pornographic
I have nowhere to go with that joke so
I'll just let you talk he doesn't know
one part that I love is that when
peppermint Butler does the arts and he
gets the armor and the sword and he goes
after them and they get to this like
mini little fight then he gets tossed
into the bag or into the Hat
which is an alternate-dimension and you
have well of course start seeing them
really go don't hurt our friend there's
like do you want to go with the bag but
then you have the guy I what was his
name start no no no the doughnut that's
right yeah I'm sure
I love the voice actor whoever does it
don't see like a movie or something I'm
probably wrong but uh I love how es the
dimensional like disrupter it's like
this thing with that pickle like take to
it but it actually works go with a bite
taken out yeah I'm like that's awesome
what I like also is remember starts he
runs a wolf or one he starts you the
gravedigger but he's also runs a
late-night radio show remember which is
all that's a supernatural which the
meaning that they're having actually
continues that along with the whole
supernatural aspect I like that I think
that's pretty neat cool plus it has
peppermint Butler in the episode and
he's always fun that the guy who voices
the peace mastery from the office Rainn
Wilson yeah he he was great in this you
know it's all about nothing like him
yeah I mean which is always great I love
when I hear a voice actor and I cannot
recognize them like even if you tell me
I'm like that can't be them yeah I
really love when that happens and it's a
pretty well-written character honestly
there's a lot for the character to work
off him but he yeah he even brings it
more to life with that voice you know I
am totally going to overthrow you you
know it's like those little touches of
you know speaking this big epic language
with some current phrases to you know
throw it in like totally and I mean it
which the show is always great at my job
yeah mixing that with like the minivan
and the family but trying to speak epic
and still having this serve evil low
voice while trying to do baby talk and
yeah I mean it's it's really great it's
I'd love to see him again I think it's a
really fun character again the design
half bandaged face the pacifier
yeah which bears say like what the
hell's the pacifier for and then when we
see the family is like oh okay Ramona
when he's about to be a pet attacked by
peppermint Butler it glows yeah
learning to find all the stuff you threw
into the ditch was it also like dolls
and playthings and stuff so it's kind of
like he took his kids stuff you know
like I get just trying to combine the
two like well I don't get that to be a
single father here but I also have to
fight carts and stuff so I'll just kind
of combine the two together yeah you
know I didn't actually think about that
but yeah good question again it just
makes it so much funnier but also says
so much about the character to that yes
he cares so much about bald-faced
willing to combine them and work off of
each other and you know make the
compromises so no it was a lot of fun no
no I went too far
what you just so legitimately concerned
that and now stop stop she's like sharks
you're underway he's like okay so he
does and him and the kids are laughing
yeah the kids are having fun with the
butler - he's doing these bad things but
then the dirt comes up and their faces
are like like he's really doing that
woman OH
peppermint Butler still one of my
favorites look I say don't mess with
peppermint Butler he's he's got the
crazies got the flaming sword hmm it's
gonna where's my chamomile tea so I
don't freak out yes sir I don't have me
will you have coca-cola from Burger King
no I will have my Mountain Dew wait
well then we'll have you have coca-cola
from Burger King oh oh wait here's my
chamomile tea or away um
animail tea with man mellow
what is man Mela oh my god what why are
you here in l a-- fired
go get the rodeo burger it's really good